[Music]
I'll just get a glass of water please I
have to save all my money cuz I'm here
to find my sister she's been taken taken
like like by man who sell hot white
virgins to conchiglie NS on yours
I am very moved by your story or their
anything you like I'll have a club
sandwich and an order fries two slices
of cake do you want any cake three
slices the cake in a diet coke
impressive I'm a con artist
sisters-in-arms I have no idea how small
time I was until I met you penny why are
women better suited to the calm than men
cuz we're used to faking it because no
man will ever believe a woman is smarter
than he is is it valuable
$500,000 I like it cuz it's shiny
I could be the partner given you needed
teach me your sugar baby ways thank you
to the guest ring Butler person first
listen there's nothing more compelling
to a man than a vulnerable woman observe
wow you just tear up like that can you
make the tea roll down your cheek oh oh
no you try are you constipated if you
want to be like me you must be trained
before any situation she's ready he's
the mark he's a tech millionaire
billionaire out there try to piss
inconspicuous as possible
yep one person working here if this
person would just scoot over would you
mind sir sir
[Music]
men always underestimate us and that is
what we used
[Music]
you let her get away huh she dresses
again
servicemen's says it sir robert dollars
is a terrible shot that wasn't expected
[Music]